استراتيجيات وتكتيكات حربيه جديده ستقلب
موازين القوى في الحرب باوكرانيا من خلال
النظام اسلحه امريكيه جديد يشمل هذه المره
معدات ذكيا متطوره وسيتم ضمها لسلاح الجو
الاوكرانيه هذه المعدات الالكترونيه سيتم
ارسالها الى الجيش الاوكراني حيث ستوفر
طريقه جديده لاستهداف الوحدات العسكريه
الروسيه ان كان في البر او الجو وفقا ما
نشرته صحيفه واشنطن بوستن التقنيه
العسكريه الجديده والتي اطلق عليها
البنتاجون ذخيره الهجوم المباشر المشترك
ستشمل بالدرجه الاولى اجهزه تحديد المواقع
العالميه كما نتابع وذلك لضمان الدقه ايضا
سيتم تثبيتها على مجموعه متنوعه من
الاسلحه كالقادفات والطائرات المقاتله
التي يستخدمها الجيش الاوكراني في تنفيذ
الهجمات المضاده ضد القوه الروسيه ايضا
سيتم تحويل
الاخوات ده خائر الجويه غير الموجهه الى
قنابل ذكيه يمكنها استهداف المواقع
العسكريه الروسيه بدرجه عاليه من الدقه
ويمكن ايضا للجيش الاوكراني ان يستخدمه
هذه التقنيه في القنابل التي يصل وزنها
الى
907 كغم القوات الاوكرانيه ستستخدم هذه
المعدات على الطائرات والاسلحه الارضيه
وكل الانظمه المحدده في ترسانه اوكرانيا
التي ستكون مرشحه لمثلي هذا التعزيز هذه
الاسلحه ايضا تعمل بشكل مختلف عن المعدات
التي توجه الصواريخ في نظام تحديد المواقع
العالميه وفي حال تم تسليم هذه المعادات
سيشكل ذلك خطوه مهمه من جانب وعلشان
لمساعدات اوكرانيا على سد القوات الروسيه